hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast assessing risk in
cervical cancer screening management the
role of HPV genotyping presented by dr.
Kathryn Baron we're excited to bring
this educational web seminar presented
by lab groups the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar is sponsored by roche
diagnostics roche is a leader in
research focus healthcare with combined
strengths in pharmaceutical and
diagnostics roche is a world largest
biotech company with truly
differentiated medicine in oncology
virology inflammation metabolome and cns
roche is also the world leader in vitro
diagnostics tissue-based cancer
diagnostics and the pioneer in diabetes
management i'm susie valdez of lab roots
i'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during this
presentation just click on a green Q&A
button located at the lower left of your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we can until the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the windows just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on a support button at the
top right of this presentation window or
use the Q&A button and let us know
you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar that offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the cee
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining those credits and
now I'd like to introduce our presenter
dr. Barron's welcome
everyone and thanks for taking time out
of the schedule to join us for this
presentation today I'll be talking about
how we might be able to improve the way
we screening for cervical cancer by
using HPV genotyping to assess each
women individual risk by the end of the
presentation I hope that we can see that
genotyping allows us to better triage
our patients in two categories of
management those who can confidently be
discharged to the next round of routine
screening those who need immediate
follow-up and those who can be deferred
to short term term follow-up my
disclosures now on the agenda will first
review briefly the background of HPV and
cervical cancer will then look at how
genotyping has been incorporated into
the guidelines are genotyping can be
used for risk management and also how
risks of progressing from pre-cancer to
invasive cancer may vary for different
genotypes finally we'll discuss how to
know typing plays a key role in the
strategy that uses HPV as the first line
primary screen for cervical cancer so
let's begin with a brief review about
what we know about HPV and cervical
cancer we know that more than 99 percent
of cervical cancers are caused by HPV
and of the 13 or so oncogenic types HPV
16 and HPV 18 are responsible for
approximately seventy percent of
invasive cancers we also know that HPV
is the most common sexually transmitted
infection approximately eighty percent
of women will be infected sometime
during their lifetime the vast majority
of these women will clear the infection
without any consequence but we know that
persistence of infection increases the
risk for cervical disease
you know that cervical cancer is the
third most common cancer in women and
the fifth cause of cancer deaths
worldwide and despite screening in the
US we'll see approximately 13,000 cases
and 40 100 deaths a year and globally
the statistics are staggering about
500,000 new cases and more than 250,000
deaths each year worldwide but the
cervical cancer story is an old bleak
make no mistake cervical cancer
screening is one of the biggest success
stories in disease prevention as this
slide shows data from the NCIC r
database demonstrates a significant
decrease in both incidence and mortality
rates from cervical cancer since the
adoption of the pap smear and to
organize screening programs but if we
look a little closer we notice that
there has been a plat telling of this
decrease in the last decade and this
raises the question of whether we have
reached the limitations of screening
with cytology if we look at the box at
the bottom you notice to the five-year
survival rates over the same period of
time have shown very little difference
the five-year survival in 1975 was 68.1
percent and in 2010 sixty seven point
nine percent so again that raises the
question of whether we can improve on
screening methodology now if you made
the argument that the plateauing of the
decreased incidence and mortality that
we see is because we haven't been able
to reach every woman for screening you
would be correct this slide shows the
results from studies done at two well
organized screening programs Kaiser and
the Swedish national health service for
this study the medical records of women
with invasive cervical cancer were
reviewed to evaluate their screening
history prior to being diagnosed
cancer as you can see in the first line
the majority diagnosed with cancer had
not had the appropriate screening but if
you look at the second line you see that
a high percentage had had psychology but
that had failed to detect any
abnormality at Kaiser this was one-third
of the women with cancer and in the
Swedish study it was one quarter now
this type of data caught the attention
of the US Preventive Services Task Force
and prompted them to commission a study
to compare the sensitivity of HPV to
psychology for the detection of
precancerous in this slide we see the
results of that meta-analysis as you can
see in each of the six studies HPV was
found to be more sensitive than
psychology and in fact on average HPV
was nearly thirty-six percent more
sensitive unfortunately HPV oval
sensitive is not very specific and that
would have to be addressed if it were to
be used as a screening strategy and
we'll discuss that in more length later
in this presentation now let's spend a
few minutes reviewing some specifics
about HPV genotypes among the 40 or so
HPV genotypes that infect the anti
genital area as mentioned in the
introductory remarks there are about 13
genotypes that are classified as high
risk or oncogenic this diagram is a
phylogenetic tree that shows the
relationship of the anogenital types in
this relationship is based on how
similar their DNA sequences are the
known high-risk types are shown in black
both classified as possibly high risk
and teal in the low risk in dark blue
all the high risk types can be found in
the two most important HPV subgroups or
claves a nine and a seven a nine
includes HPV 16 and other related types
while a 7 includes a
tv18 and its sequence similar types the
Clay's take on significance in that when
cross-reactivity occurs with HPV
vaccines hpv-16 for example will cross
protect against the members of clay 9
and HPV 18 against members of clade 7 so
what is the significance of the various
genotypes to screening this slide shows
results from a study conducted at Kaiser
Permanente Portland that was the first
large prospective study to examine
whether the value of HPV testing could
be optimized by using separate detection
of the most important genotypes in this
study women have their HPD status
determined at baseline and then we'll
follow up to ten years to see what their
risk of developing cin 3 plus would be
now for those not familiar with the
terminology cin is an acronym the
cervical intraepithelial neoplasia cin 3
represents the highest stage of cin cin
3 plus includes cin 3 adenocarcinoma
inside to an invasive cancer and cin 3
plus is often used as a surrogate for
cervical cancer but as you can see on
these graphs women who were infected at
baseline with HPV 16 next the red line
had the highest risk of developing cin 3
plus over 10 years of hpv16 that was
over seventeen percent for HPV 18 the
blue line the risk was thirteen point
six percent and the risk for the
remaining genotypes was only three point
zero percent and you can also see that
the risk in women who are tested HP the
negative at baseline was less than 1%
0.8% now it was as was mentioned in the
introductory comments
PC 16 and 18 are responsible together
for seventy percent of cervical cancers
that estimate comes from the data
published by dr san jose from Spain who
determined the genotype distribution in
invasive cervical cancers from 18 from
38 countries testing more than 20,000
cancer specimens this stacking graph
shows the distribution in squamous cell
cancers and we can see that most
sixty-two percent of the cancers are
hpv-16 positive well only about eight
percent of squamous cell cancers are 18
positives on the other hand and add no
carcinomas we see that HPV 18 is
responsible for a much higher percentage
thirty-two percent and together with HPV
16 they account for more than eighty
percent of invasive cancers we also see
on this next slide that is also from dr
san jose's data that the seventy percent
combined contribution of HPV 16 and 18
holds true globally although the
proportion of cancers distributed
between 16 and 18 they vary slightly
from continent to continent and over
multiple races and ethnicities we see
that 16 and 18 are consistently
responsible for about seventy percent of
the cancers but what can we say about
the remaining thirty percent of cancers
other other genotypes that are major
contributors for example HPV 45 has
received considerable attention now we
can explore this question using data
from the Athena study a large us
screaming study that enrolled more than
47,000 women this bar graph shows both
the prevalences and risk of cin 2 plus
in cin 3 plus for each of five genotypes
in women 30 years and older not
surprisingly HPV 16 and 18 have the
highest risk but HPV 31 is only slightly
lower followed by HPV 33
with HPV 45 having a relatively low
prevalence and risk it's also worth
pointing out that only genotyping with
HPV 16 and 18 is supported by the
current guidelines now this next slide
shows similar results from dr. Schiffman
at NIH who analyzed data from 20,000
women who were followed at Kaiser
Portland for up to 15 years if we look
at the graph we see agreement with the
Athena data in that HPV 16 imparts the
highest risk followed by HPV 18 and then
31 of dope HPV 45 again did not show a
risk distinguishable from the remaining
genotypes now Russia's R&D group was
aware of data like these but
demonstrated the oncogene missa T of HPV
16 and 18 and they specifically designed
an assay that optimize screening to
identify women at the highest risk so
the system they designed the cobas HPV
reports out not only pooled h can be
status but it also provides separate
results for hdb 16 and 18 not as a
reflex test but as an integrated result
that is reported out simultaneously with
the pooled result and the way this is
accomplished is with a four channel
system that is diagrammed on this side
the first channel reports that results
for the non 16 18 12 other genotypes the
second channel for HPV 16 the third
channel for each could be 18 and the
fourth child is an internal beta golden
control that confirms the presence of
DNA and the absence of inhibitory
substances so next let's talk about
genotype about how genotypes has been
adopted into the evolving guidelines for
cervical cancer screening this slide
from the american society of colposcopy
and cervical pathology shows the
original algorithm the managing Co
testing results in women 30 years and
older now the challenge with co testing
is that often one of the co test
partners will be positive and the other
negative and this means that an
additional management decision is
necessary to resolve the Discordians in
this algorithm we are evaluating women
who have had co testing with a negative
psychology result and I should mention
this is another algorithm known that
stamps are negative for inter epithelial
region on malignancy now there's no
question that a negative psychology and
a negative HPV yield a clear negative
result and as a consequence these women
can be dismissed from screaming until
the appropriate interval for rescreening
as is diagrammed on the far left however
in the case of a negative path in a
positive HPV result additional
evaluation needs to be happened needs to
happen and that's indicated by the next
arrow to the right in 2006 the
guidelines recommended a repeat code
test in 12 months but this deferred
management was problematic for both
patient and clinician raising anxiety on
both parts
the other issue with this deferred
strategy is that loves to follow up that
can occur during the 12-month period and
it is well documented that on average
approximately twenty percent of women
will be lost to follow-up in cervical
cancer screening programs but once HPV
assays with genotype and became
available clinicians had an alternative
to deferring women with negative path
with but with positive HPV results in
2009 a sccp revised their guidelines to
include the option of co testing with
genotyping that is psychology performed
along with a TV test that would also
provide specifically results for HPV 16
and 18 this algorithm again women
negatives for both tests are returned to
routine screening while women with
negative psychology and positive for
either HPV 16 or 18 are sent to
immediate colposcopy since they have
been identified to have the highest risk
of having high grade cervical disease
then we see that only those women who
are positive for the non 1618 less
oncogenic genotypes are deferred to
12-month follow-up for repeat code
testing this co testing with genotype
option eliminates the some anxiety and
also the possibility of loss to
follow-up of women or at the highest
risk I think most clinicians agree that
this is a step towards optimizing
cervical cancer screening now following
along with the evolution and guidelines
in 2012 unprecedented joint guidelines
were issued by three major professional
organizations the American Cancer
Society a sec p and the american society
of clinical pathology there were many
changes proposed but one of the major
changes was to advise that co testing
rather than psychology alone was now the
preferred strategy for screaming women
30 years and older as you can see in
this joint publication the
recommendation for co testing also
endorse the option of triaging women
with negative psychology with HPV 16 and
18 positivity to capacity rather than
deferring to 12-month follow-up now that
we've seen how HPV 16 18 and optimize
screening by identifying women at the
highest risk for high-grade disease and
that the guidelines support the use of
genotyping let's speak more specifically
about how genotyping can be used to
quantitate women's risk and
individualized management strategy now
this slide again will show data from the
Athena study and it provides important
information for managing Co testing
results in women 30 years and older who
have a negative path or who are
hpv-positive here we'll be looking at
the absolute risk at CIN 3 plus
stratified by the results from the
various Cobus HPV channels and I should
mention that throughout this
presentation that will be primarily
showing data for cin 3 plus since it is
less likely to regress and say i am too
plus and therefore represents more
clinically relevant to deals now we see
in this first bar that if we look at the
absolute risk of a negative path
independent of HPV it's pretty low at
point five percent and if we add to that
a negative cold high risk HPV that's all
14 genotypes you see that the absolute
risk is lower still 0.3% on the other
hand a positive pool HPV raises the
absolute risk to about four percent but
the real risk stratification is apparent
when we look at the Kobach's HPV
categories we see that the four percent
risk is better defined for example if
HPV is passe
the 12 other types the absolute risk
decreases to about two percent well at
hpv16 positive result where is the
absolute risk to nearly twelve percent
and HPV 18 imparts an intermediate risk
of about six percent so keep in mind
these are all risk for women with
negative paths that means that without
the genotyping option for managing
discordant Co testing results women with
a negative path and a positive for
pooled high-risk HPV would be deferred
to follow up in 12 months yet if woman
is 16 positive she has a 12-percent
absolute risk to cin three plugs or
another way to look at it is one out of
eight women with a negative path who is
16 positive has cin 3 plus to me is a
gynecologist it was startling to see
that the risk was so high and that we
are also adding to the risk with the
possibility of loss to follow-up with
deferral we can also look at the
stratification when HPV testing is used
as an adjunctive test to ask this
cytology although the guidelines advise
the risk of a skiff cytology with any
positive experience ult is high enough
to warrant referral to capacity it's
still helpful to quantitate the risk
stratified by the various HPV types in
this slide again we're looking at the
absolute risk of cin 3 plus but now in
women with a skiff cytology rather than
a negative pap results we see that the
absolute risk for cin 3 rogaska cytology
independent of HPV is about 3% and that
this decreases tenfold to 0.3% if the
pooled HPV well result is negative which
is why women with a skiff cytology who
are HPV negative are not sent to
colposcopy on the other hand the
absolute risk increases to more than
eight percent if pulled
TV is positive and again that's a risk
felt to be high enough to want referral
to colposcopy and will speak more about
that about the risk cut point for
management decisions in a few minutes
now we can stratify the eight percent
risk further with Cobus results that
indicate that if HPV positivity is due
to 12 other genotypes that the risk
decreases to have about four percent
however in women who are hpv-16 positive
the absolute risk the cin 3 plus is
highest at 21 and again an intermediate
risk for HPV 18 at about four percent
and so although the genotyping was asked
if cytology will not be used to decide
which women go to colposcopy the risk
stratification is helpful in guiding
post colposcopy management since the
majority of women with a skew cytology
who are cold HPV positive will not be
found to have high grade disease on
colposcopy the risk stratification can
help identify who is at highest risk and
who might need close follow-up or more
intensive efforts to assure compliance
with follow-up as long as the genotype
results are generated automatically with
code by HPV not as a separate reflex
test why not incorporated as a factor in
individual risk profile of each patient
and that helps a segue into the next
section of the presentation we will
discuss more specifically the risk
assessment model for cervical cancer
screening so we've seen how the cobas
HPV text or other expedia phase which
genotype is a reflex test can help
stratify risk but now we can look more
specifically at a model of risk
assessment for cervical cancer screening
that is beginning to emerge as more
technologies for screening are developed
at present we have only psychology HPV
testing with partial genotyping and
histology is tools in the future the US
will also have more sophisticated
imaging
systems as well as biomarkers such as
p16 ki67 a methylation and these likely
will be used in algorithms to calculate
the rich a risk for each woman based on
all of her screening results so now I'd
like to review how the risk assessment
model works today within the existing
technologies so we'll be familiar with
the concept were more sophisticated
algorithms incorporating newer
technologies are introduced now in 2007
dr. Kassel proposed a risk assessment
model based on psychology pooled HPV and
remember HPV genotyping assays were not
yet developed and histology in this
colorful slide we see how he assigned a
risk and this is again for cin
three-plus based on results from the
existing technologies used the screen it
was really the first attempt to
quantitate risk and assign management
strategies based on the magnitude of
that risk for example it was proposed
that a woman with the risk of cin three
below two percent as determined for the
screening results for example- cytology
or negative HPV with a skiff cytology
was considered sufficiently low to allow
her to have routine follow-up a risk at
or above ten percent and I would be 4l
soo on HPV positive asker's warranted
immediate colposcopy while those with
risk between two and ten percent for
example HPV positive psychology negative
could be deferred to short-term
follow-up on the higher end of the
spectrum those were the risk greater
than forty percent and note that this is
a compressed scale for example h so
would have a response i could be
counseled
about proceeding to immediate treatment
in 2006 dr. cat Castle expanded on his
risk assessment model to include HPV
genotyping and on the next several
slides I will be showing data from his
recent publication that looked at CIN 3
plus risks in women with negative taps
at one year which would be the risk of
co testing without genotyping was
practiced this is similar to the risk
stratification serving Athena data that
we looked at before but I think it's
helpful to see it again in the context
of the castle risk assessment model so
we see here if we have for example HPV
positives and cytology negatives the
risk is below ten percent and would not
want immediate colposcopy however with
the genotyping option we could see that
the HPV if positive for HPV 16 and
psychology negative would give an
absolute risk about ten percent and that
would warrant immediate colposcopy we
see something similar for HPV positive
in a skiff cytology the risk is
approximately ten percent and that
warrants immediate colposcopy but with
the genotyping option we see that the
risk if the HPV was positive for HPV 16
rises to about twenty percent and again
this would be useful for the management
in post copas coupee we see similar
results for HPV positive else'll and HPV
16 positive else oh and of course with
HPV positive L so the wear
to begin with is very high about forty
percent and with HPV 16 ACH so the risk
rises to nearly eighty percent so again
consideration for immediate treatment
could be considered and we see similar
with stratification with HPV 18 now the
next topic that I'd like to cover has to
do with using cin three-plus at the
surrogate to cervical cancer as
mentioned before cin 3 plus includes cin
3 adenocarcinoma inside too and cancer
now in order to calculate risks whether
it be for psychology or HPV results or
newer technologies that will be used in
the future it's necessary to conduct
large studies that generate adequate
numbers of disease cases and although
we'd like to be able to calculate added
risk for developing invasive cancer
obviously that's the ultimate end point
there are not usually sufficient
cervical cancer cases detected in the
studies that allow us to calculate the
list at least those studies that are
conducted in developed countries so
that's how we came to you see iron
three-plus as a surrogate to cervical
cancer but most part cin 3 plus serves
as an adequate surrogate but i'd like to
present some additional data from the
same group that spain we saw earlier who
determine the HPV genotypes status of
the cervical cancers globally this study
here looked at the percent HPP
positivity at various stages of cervical
disease which is shown on this graph I'd
like to focus on the right side that
uses the histology diagnosis to define
disease stage we can see that the HPP
positivity of hpv16 rises sharply that's
the blue curve through all stages of
disease and in particular from cin 32
invasive cervical cancer we see a
similar
transfer it to the 18 the red line but
then a fairly flat line for HPV 45 it's
the green line looking at the data this
way seems to indicate that not all CI m3
has the same tendency to become invasive
cancer this concept can also be
expressed by looking at the invasive
cancer to normal ratio which will be
higher with the oncogenic genotypes and
you can see that to the right the next
graph shows the similar plots for
additional genotyped which again on the
right side show even sharper declines
and percent positivity for example four
genotypes 31 33 and 52 icc to normal
ratios likewise are much lower than for
HPV 16 and 18 now this isn't to say that
these other genotypes can't cause
invasive cervical cancer but rather
they're onto genesee maybe less than HPV
16 or 18 and this is an unexpected since
as we discussed these two genotypes are
responsible for seventy percent of all
cancers we looked at a similar analysis
from the Athena study for a much lower
number of invasive cancer cases were
detected than in the study from staying
so we had to use cin 3 plus as the end
point but interestingly we saw much the
same trends there was an increase in
positivity from cin to to cin 3 + 33 16
and 18 those of the blue and red curves
while the remaining genotypes show the
fall off esther HPV 31 which we saw
demonstrated a risk for CI + 3 + that
was similar to HPV 16 and 18 in both
Athena and the Kaiser portman studies
but here it shows a downward curve as
disease progresses so we may need
additional data before we can say
whether HPV 31 to be given the same
aggressive response is HPV 16 and 18 1
and keep in mind again
HPV 16 and 18 are the only genotypes
that are currently supported by the
guidelines for risk assessment now I'd
like to take the last few minutes of
this presentation to illustrate how to
you know typing and risk assessment I
used in a practical and timely
application as you may be aware the FDA
granted approval in 2014 HPV to be used
in women 25 years and older as the first
line primary screen and cervical cancer
an HPV genotyping plays an important
role in that strategy before we discuss
the specifics of the primary screening
algorithm I want to step back for a
minute and review the reasoning behind
using HPV rather than psychology as the
primary screen and the challenges that
that presents first it has been pretty
well established that HPV is more
sensitive than psychology of the
detection of pre-cancer we saw that on
the slide from US Preventive Services
Task Force and other analysis but we
also know that HPV has limited
specificity surely not all women who
have HPV infection going to develop
cervical disease and in any screening
strategy that makes sense to use the
more sensitive test first so that we
test the widest nest net to capture all
who may be at risk but we need to follow
up that sensitive test with a more
specific triage for the risk over
managing and over treating patients
while working on a primary screening
strategy it became clear that an
algorithm would need to be developed
that provided the best balance between
sensitivity and specificity so I'd like
to review how we came to developed a
balanced strategy one that received fda
approval and is supported by several
professional societies and you'll see
how HPV 16 18 genotyping plays an
integral role
in the strategy this bill slide this
build slide will show the FDA approved
algorithm for HPV primary screening
using the cobas HPV test let's walk
through it and see how we were able to
use 1618 genotyping to help provide the
balance of sensitivity and specificity
that you needed as diagrammed we start
with Cobus HPV test and those women who
test HPV negative can confidently be
dismissed to routine follow-up in three
years we know that more than ninety nine
percent cervical cancers are attributed
to HPV so it makes sense that if an HPV
infection isn't present that there's
very little risk of cervical disease we
also saw in data from Athena that it in
present today but the risk of cin 3 plus
over three years with a negative HPV
result is very low 0.3% well below the
threshold for colposcopy or even
short-term follow-up now those who test
hpv-positive we know that if it's HPV 16
or HPV 18 those are at the highest
forest so they'll pursue two colposcopy
now we have the remaining women who test
to the 12 other non 1618 to triage and
again this would be a high percentage of
women to send to capacity so those are
triaged with with psychology those who
have abnormal psychology will go to cope
osku p and those with normal cytology
would be deferred to short-term
follow-up since they're still
hpv-positive now to address the concern
that HPV isn't specific enough and that
it would send too many women to
colposcopy we can evaluate that by
looking
the percent calculated for each result
in the screening strategy we see that
approximately ninety percent of the
women will test age can be negative and
will be sent to routine follow-up of the
ten percent that are hpv-positive only
about four point seven percent would be
referred to capacity that's the two
point nine plus one point eight percent
and that is compared to psychology as
the first line screen where this percent
can be considerably higher depending on
your labs percent for abnormal
psychology and we'll return to the issue
of sensitivity and specificity of
primary screening with additional data
over the next few slides now to
illustrate that HPV primary screening
provides improvement and sensitivity
while maintaining specificity I'd like
to compare primary screening performance
to the two current accepted strategies
psychology alone and co testing now
psychology will include HPV triage
basket so that HPV negative ascus
psychology women are not taken to
colposcopy as per guidelines and will
also compared to a hybrid co testing
strategy that requires a little
explanation since HPV primary screening
is approved for women 25 years and older
the co testing only for women 30 years
and older were used a hybrid co testing
strategy where women 25 to 29 was
screened with psychology alone and those
sorry little slide problem here in those
30 and older with co testing now this
slide will see a build of the
comparisons of performance parameters
for all three screening strategies
sensitivity and specificity are
expressed relative to the sensitivity
and specificity for psychology so those
parameters
cytology will be defined as one for the
positive predictive value and negative
predictive value we use the actual
values we see that for the hybrid
strategy sensitivity relative to
psychology is 1.28 meaning that it was
increased by twenty eight percent
specificity was equal to psychology and
npv is slightly higher now for HPV
primary screening we see an even greater
increase in sensitivity forty percent
higher than psychology alone and twelve
percent higher than the hybrid co
testing strategy and both are
significant increases it's a little
counterintuitive to see that the
sensitivity for HPV primary screening is
higher than Co testing that again
remember that the hybrid co testing
strategy includes the cohort of women 25
to 29 who just had cytology steering per
the guidelines and specificity for
primary screening is not lower than
psychology alone while PPV and npv are
improved over both psychology alone
penco testing so we took the comparison
one step further and wanted to see how
the strategies would perform in a
clinical situation so this we compared
the number of cin 3 plus cases detected
which is a clinical measure of
sensitivity the number of tests required
by the strategy and also the number of
copas capiz expressed both as the total
and as the ratio of co pasta p / cin 3 +
detected which is a clinical surrogate
for specificity as we can see HPV
primary screening the text highest
number of cin 3 plus cases required only
slightly more tests and psychology alone
and nearly half is co testing and
although it required the most colposcopy
when expressed as the ratio of capacity
to cin 3 + detective it's no higher than
Co testing
now since we definitely review the lot
of data in short time let's see what
conclusions we can draw first and
foremost cervical cancer is a
preventable disease and that can't be
stressed enough it provides the perfect
model for screening we know what causes
it we have good screening tools which
improve over time with new technology
and the strategies such as primary
screening we're also fortunate that the
cervix is accessible to biopsy so that
we can detect pre-cancer in addition you
have good treatment options when pre
cancers diagnosed and it's also an
indolent disease with a long
precancerous stage that allows for
adequate time to screen diagnose and
treat so this is truly the low-hanging
fruit preventable disease the second
conclusion I want to propose is that HPV
was sixteen eighteen genotyping and it
remains to be seen if additional
genotypes will be elevated to a similar
risk level it's a valuable tool that
allows us to identify who is it the
highest risk and would benefit from
immediate colposcopy and conversely who
is at lower risk and can confidently be
referred to routine or short-term
follow-up and in Co testing 1618
genotyping also has the advantage of
decreasing the loss to follow-up of
those women were significant disease
since we avoid deferring their
assessment for 12 months and lastly 1618
genotyping if in the primary screening
strategy provides the balance of
specificity to the improved sensitivity
and as such primary screening offers
another option to optimize screening so
in closing I'd like to thank you for
your attention and for your continued
efforts to promote the prevention of
cervical cancer I'll turn it back over
to Susie now
thank you dr. Barron for that
informative presentation it's time for
our Q&A now if you have any questions
you'd like to ask dr. Baron please click
on the green QA button at the lower left
of your presentation window type in your
questions into the box that appear on
that screen and click and send on the
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question dr. Baron
will follow up via email after the
presentation so let's start with our
first question dr. Baron do you think
that additional HPV genotypes other than
16 and 18 will be adopted into the
guidelines the triaging cytology
negative HPV positive results in co
testing well that's a great question
Susie and I think first to address the
technical issue there is at present no
HPV sa the testing a approved that can
identify any other genotypes font size
makes me be 16 and there's 1a say that
identified who HPV 18 along with 45 so
until that assay is developed an
fda-approved nothing will happen if that
should occur and other genotypes can be
detected with an fda-approved test I
think it will take some time for that to
get into the guidelines the guidelines
require a fair man of data and as as we
saw through the presentation the
prevalence of these other genotypes it's
fairly low so it's very difficult to do
studies that have adequate numbers of
women infected with what genotypes other
than 16 and 18 with significant disease
so that that we can show that their risk
is high enough to warrant going to
immediate colposcopy
so I think to summarize the response
time will tell whether other genotypes
make it into the guidelines but first
we'll need an assay that's at the
approve to identify them and that and
then a fair amount of data to convince
the people who make the guidelines that
this warrants being in the guidelines so
this will take some time thank you for
that response dr. Baron had a great
question from an audience number why is
the new screening interval five years
for negative co tests and three years
for a negative HPV primary screen result
I'll start with primary screening the
reason why in the US the rescreening
after a negative HPV primary screen is
three years is because that is what was
shown in the Athena data as I mentioned
in the presentation a woman who had a
negative HPV test at baseline at three
years had a risk of cin 3 plus of 0.3%
so the Athena data was able to show the
safety of the negative HPV test over
three years now for Co testing it was
decided that five year interval with
both partners of the co test of
psychology and HPV being negative would
be appropriate was because that whisk
was similar to what the risk would be
for a pap smear at three years and they
felt that that you know should be the
gold standard I should mention though
that even though the screening interval
for a negative co test is five years
that many clinicians if not most
clinicians are very uncomfortable with
the length of that interval they seem to
be much more comfortable with
three year interval which is is what is
recommended with negative HPV is a
primal scream thank you for that we have
a lot of great questions coming in but
we only have time for one more dr. Baron
you mentioned that you focused only on a
risk for developing cin 3 plus since it
is more clinically relevant disease but
isn't that threshold for treatment in
the u.s. cin 2 plus yes up until the
2012 new guidelines that i had mentioned
were unprecedented joint guidelines the
recommendation had been traditionally at
least in the US but the treatment
threshold dcin to and that allowed for
you know a little bit of era you know
and in favor of getting the benefit
patients benefit of the doubt in case
the cin to was really cin 3 however in
the 2012 guidelines the recommendation
was made that certainly in younger women
the threshold should be raised to cin 3
plus and that it should be considered
depending on a patient situation now of
course if you have you know a 45 year
old woman who's completed her
childbearing and have had you know
persistent cin to then her clinician may
decide that the best treatment for her
would be to have an excisional or an
ablative treatment of cin too but for
the most part the trend is going towards
treatment thresholds of cin 3 plus
particularly in young women prior to
childbearing
dr. Baron thank you again for this very
important and informative presentation
do you have any final comments you'd
like to share with the audience it's
just to again thank them for their
attention and to their diligence and
screaming women for cervical cancer
because again we can't stress enough
that this this is a preventable disease
and we would like to see a continuation
of the decrease in the incidents and the
mortality not only here in the US but
globally as well
thank you again dr. Barron I'd also like
to thank lab roots today for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through July 2017 you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please please
share this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thanks for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon bye bye
you